digitization is in my opinion one of the
significant opportunities we have in our
in our times we saw how digitization
radically transformed the music industry
and the result is pretty significant
that you have more an easier consumption
of music today and a fraction of the
cost in terms of delivery this was just
the first industry to go through a
radical transformation due to
digitization we have for the first time
in history an opportunity to reach
billions of people directly on their
mobile device we have an incredible
opportunity to share knowledge and
individualize offerings like never
before
imagine healthcare where the DNA
analysis of individual patients can
allow for a very targeted individual
therapy proposal and would that of
course increase party efficiency and
improve people's lives dramatically this
will happen in all industries in my
opinion and therefore this is now a
moment when leaders need to embrace the
opportunity need to rethink their
business models and basically need to
become IT companies in every industry
in my opinion the digitisation is the
biggest opportunity we have to make sure
that every person on this planet gets a
relevant education first and foremost we
have an incredible knowledge that has
been collected through billions of
people adding their knowledge to the
Internet and secondly for the first time
in history we can reach people
everywhere at basically zero costs we
made some experiments at sa P where we
have taken our learning platform and
offered open classes not just in a
physical classroom but actually in a
virtual classroom would the engagement
that you will see in a physical
classroom and the results are just
amazing we are reaching more than 10,000
students in one training class more than
two and a half thousand students are
graduating from the class and that based
on one effort so in that sense you could
argue that the digitisation is the
biggest opportunity we have to make sure
that everyone everywhere in the world
get the relevant education
I strongly believe that it is our duty
as leaders to transform and inspire not
based on a threat but an opportunity and
we have enormous opportunity right now I
believe the most difficult question is
how can we initiate transformation a
radical transformation of companies that
are successful at changing a company
that's in trouble is always easy because
there is no other choice so I think that
is the key question that we need to ask
ourselves and the difficult question is
how can I change it's kind of if it
isn't broken consider fixing it and
that's I think is very relevant in the
moment way now where the digitization
offers so many new opportunities but we
also lack the skills to get it done we
need to take the lead I believe we are
lucky to be leaders in a world or
radical change but we also have an
obligation to be proactive in leading
that change and creating